un homme a deux enfants l'un d'eux est
un garçon quelle est la probabilité que
l'autre soit un garçon aussi on a vu la
dernière fois la solution qui me semble
être la solution bayésienne à cette
énigme et elle vous est sans doute paru
insatisfaisante puisque ça finit en mode
c'est compliqué et ça dépend on croirait
une ville aux deux oreca sur l'économie
et ça peut donner l'impression que tous
les avis se valent
ce n'est pas le cas même si les réponses
viennent sont subjectives
elles ne sont pas arbitraire elles sont
le fruit d'un calcul c'est juste que
chacun d'entre nous va avoir des
préjugés différents sur les valeurs des
composants du calcul
mais même ces préjugés ne sont pas
arbitrées en particulier quand je dis ça
dépend c'est que ça dépend vraiment de
beaucoup de choses ça dépend notamment
fortement du contexte comme le dit un
proverbe bayésiens sans conteste sans
contexte c'est la mauvaise probabilité
conteste aujourd'hui on va voir à quel
point le contexte est déterminant avec
trois variantes man fuck des deux
enfants
imaginez que vous rencontriez monsieur
smith à l'école de votre enfant
monsieur smith ou dis alors que ses deux
enfants vont dans cette école un peu
plus tard dans la journée au moment
d'aller aux toilettes
vous rencontrez dans les toilettes des
hommes un garçon et après une très
courte discussion
l'enfant vous dit que monsieur smith et
son père quelle est la probabilité que
l'autre enfants de monsieur smith qui va
cette école est un garçon lui aussi je
vous invite à mettre poser à réfléchir à
cette énigme
allez je vous laisse encore cinq
secondes alors d'un côté on pourrait se
dire que vu qu'on était dans les
toilettes et des hommes
tout enfant de monsieur smith qu'on a pu
y rencontrer ne pouvait être qu'un
garçon du coup il faut faire le
résonnement monsieur smith a au moins un
garçon plutôt que le raisonnement
un garçon de monsieur smith tirés au
hasard est un garçon c'est ce que j'ai
cru il n'y a pas si longtemps et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai écrit
publiquement sur twitter et ce beaucoup
trop à l'affirmative si vous voulez à
vis de mon moi du prison mais ce que je
viens de présenter n'est pas un
raisonnement bayésiens en particulier il
a un vague air de raisonnement par
compatibilité qui devrait désormais vous
rendre sceptique
faisons le raisonnement de bayésiens a
priori les enfants de monsieur smith qui
vont avec cette école son garçon garçon
garçon fille fille garçon ou fille et
ses quatre cas sont à peu près et plus
probable
maintenant si on restreint l'observation
à mon passage dans les toilettes quels
sont les termes d'expérience de pensée
et bien c'est intéressant de noter que
c'est globalement peu probable que l'on
y voit un des enfants de monsieur smith
autrement dit ça reste surprenant de
rencontrer l'un des enfants de monsieur
smith dans les toilettes
a priori on ne s'y attend pas bien sûr
ça dépend de si ce sont des garçons des
filles
mais même si monsieur smith a deux
garçons ça reste peu probable qu'on
trouve l'un de ces garçons dans les
toilettes lorsqu on y va pour chaque
garçon appelant epsilon la probabilité
de rencontrer un garçon dans les
toilettes
alors si epsilon est très petit en
supposant garçon garçon il semble y
avoir une probabilité d'environ 2
epsilon de rencontrer l'un des enfants
dans les toilettes d'une certaine
manière chaque garçon correspond à une
probabilité ypsilon donc deux garçons ça
fait 2 epsilon les termes d'expérience
de pensée pour les cas avec un seul
garçon correspondent eux à une
vraisemblance des données égal à epsilon
enfin dans le cas fifi la donne et je
rencontre un garçon de monsieur smith
dans les toilettes des hommes n'a aucune
chance d'arriver le score de garçon
garçon est alors deux fois celui de
garçons
puis et il était aussi deux fois celui
de filles deux garçons il représente
donc la moitié de tous les scores ont
conclus donc que l'autre enfant a une
probabilité d'environ un demi d'être un
garçon aussi
bon les résultats de cette première
énigme heures reste légèrement et
contextuelle et approximatifs et ça
embête sans doute encore les plus
matheux parmi vous du coup je vous
propose une autre variante des deux
enfants qui cette fois aura une réponse
univoque
cette fois on rencontre monsieur
logicien pour la première fois on lui
demande avez-vous deux enfants monsieur
logicien répond oui puis on lui demande
avez vous au moins un garçon né un mardi
il répond à nouveau oui quelle est la
probabilité que l'autre enfant soit un
garçon lui aussi encore une fois je vous
invite à mettre pause et cette fois il
ya une réponse unique à trouver cette
énigme avait été posée par un étudiant
trolls qui était venu me coller à la fin
d'un cours de probabilités que
j'enseignais à l'école polytechnique de
montréal en 2013
il m'avait d'abord posé la question on
sait juste que monsieur logiciel a au
moins garçons et avait répondu un tiers
comme attendu mais quand il a rajouté
que monsieur logicien à au moins un
garçon né un mardi j'étais perdu cette
information ne me semblait pas
pertinente et du coup j'ai répondu un
tiers avec quand même pas mal
d'hésitations car je sentais bien qu'il
y avait un piège mais si la question
n'avait pas été posée comme une énigme
j'aurais certainement répondu un tiers
sans aucun marqueur de modestie
épistémique et de doutes sur ma réponse
j'aurais été en plein d'excès de
confiance
oui car la bonne réponse à cette énigme
n'est pas un tiers et oui aussi étrange
que cela puisse paraître à prendre comme
moi un des enfants est un garçon né un
mardi suffit à modifier la crédence
adéquate à avoir sur le sexe de l'autre
enfant c'est super bizarre et j'ai
vraiment mis des années à aiguilles et
mon intuition pour qu'ils comprennent
pourquoi c'est le cas noté que marianne
vos savante a introduit une variante
plus pragmatique à ce problème à savoir
la différence entre savoir que dans une
main de poker à cinq cartes
il ya au moins un as et le fait de
savoir que dans une main de poker il y à
l'as de pique contre laquelle de ces
deux mains préfère et riez vous jouez
revenons à monsieur logicien pourquoi la
réponse ne reste-t-elle pas un tiers
encore une fois pour mieux comprendre ce
qu'il se passe il faut s'attarder sur
ces fameuses expérience de pensée
imaginez que monsieur logicien à deux
garçons quelle est la probabilité qu'au
moins 1 soit un garçon né un mardi pour
chaque garçon la probabilité d'être
sonné un mardi et un septième mais il
faut faire un peu attention à ne pas
compter deux fois le
où les deux enfants sont nés un mardi et
pour y arriver on peut utiliser la loi
de probabilité du ou qu'on a vu dans
l'épisode de ce qui nous donne
probabilité da donné ça chante et qui
est égale donc à la probabilité de
garçons un mardi ou garçons de mardi
sachant que garçon garçon est égale à la
probabilité de garçons à mardi sachant
garçon garçon plus la probabilité de
garçons 2 sachant garçon garçon - la
probabilité de garçons 1 mardi et
garçons de mardi sachant qu'un garçon
garçon
ce qui nous fait un septième plus un
septième mois 1 49e qui est égal à cette
49e puis cette 49ème - 1 49e
et donc ça c'est aussi cette puisse être
moins 1 / 49 qui est égal à 13 49e
a contrario dans les cafés garçons et
garçons filles les termes d'expérience
de penser correspondent uniquement au
cas où le garçon est né un mardi ce qui
correspond une probabilité de 1 7e qui
était aussi égal à cette 49e autrement
dit et c'est vraiment ça que j'aimerais
que vous reteniez on est presque deux
fois plus surpris d'apprendre comment un
garçon est né un mardi dans le cas
filles et garçons que dans le cas car
son garçon et oui après tout
intuitivement dans le cas d'un garçon
garçon
c'est comme si on jouait deux fois au
loto on a presque deux fois plus de
chances de gagner le gros lot au moins
une fois
bon en se posant ainsi qu'à voir le gros
lot savoir un garçon né mardi ce qui est
un peu une analogie foreuse pour
faciliter les calculs je vous propose de
multiplier les scores des différentes
théories par quatre fois 49
si bien que les scores démultiplier sont
maintenant 13 pour garçon garçon 7 pour
garçons filles et sept pour filles et
garçons
le total des scores est égal à 13 plus
être plus est est égale à 27
du coup la probité que l'autre en france
ont un garçon c'est à dire la
probabilité de garçon garçon garçon
sachant notamment qu' au moins un des
enfants est un garçon né un mardi est
égal à 13 27 yens autrement dit
quasiment un demi mais pas tout à fait
en apprenant le coût du mardi on est
passé de un tiers à quasiment un demi
étrange on je vous invite vraiment à
méditer cela est ainsi de faire en sorte
que ce raisonnement bézian deviennent
intuitif chez vous
enfin on va finir cette vidéo
une troisième variante introduite par
lustres successeur en qu'open de martin
garner et mariposa vente à savoir
mickaël launay dans un sondage twitter
michael a demandé à ses abonnés
d'imaginer un couple de leur entourage
qui a deux enfants dont au moins un est
un garçon puis chaque abonné de michael
devait dire si l'autre enfants de ce
couple était un garçon ou une fille
et là vous pouvez parier sur les
statistiques du sondage
d'après vous la proportion de réponses
l'autre enfant est un garçon est égal à
combien un tiers un demi ou quelque
chose d'autre
là cette fois j'ai été plus prudent et
j'ai affirmé que je ne savais pas trop à
quoi m'attendre
c'est bien je suis content de voir que
le lait du passé à progresser dans terme
de modestie épistémique par contre est
comme mon envie de lui [ __ ] une tarte
il aura dû parier cet idiot c'était
l'occasion parfaite de lancer un
parisien et de quantifier l'étendue de
son ignorance
désolé de m'énerver ainsi mais ces
idioties du lait du passé et vous qu'en
pensez vous quels sont les résultats du
sondage de michael qui vous semble
probable
plutôt un tiers plutôt un demi plus tôt
autre chose et bien ce qui est marrant
c'est que les statistiques du sondage
donne 42% pour l'autre enfant est un
garçon c'est à dire pile poil entre un
tiers et un demi un peu comme si
l'intelligence collective des abonnés de
michael était en train de nous trop les
maximales mans et by the way on est très
loin d'une fluctuation statistiques en
fait d'après la méthode fréquentes east
de la paix value sur lequel on reviendra
plus tard on peut rejeter avec cette
sigma c'est à dire bien plus que le
standard de la physique des particules
les réponses un tiers et un demi je
trouve ça complètement fou la réponse
ici est vraiment ni un tiers ni un demi
mais alors pourquoi 42%
pourquoi 42 et bien parce que c'est la
réponse ultime à la vie l'univers et
tout le reste
non je déconne en fait à bien y
réfléchir c'est tellement débile de le
faire un poster d'écart ça pue le biais
de confirmation
on aurait pu s'attendre à quelque chose
entre un tiers et un demi en fait tout
semble surtout dépendre de si les sondés
de michael pense plutôt aux parents aux
enfants
oui car il ya deux manières de penser à
un parent dont l'un des enfants est un
garçon soit on pense à des parents et on
liste des parents jusqu'à tomber sur un
parent a deux enfants dont l'un est un
garçon
auquel cas on tombe sur une probabilité
un tiers que l'autre soit un garçon ou
sinon on pense à des enfants et il est
assez naturel de réfléchir à des garçons
qui ont un seul frangin auquel cas la
probabilité que l'autre soit un garçon
sera un demi et ce qui se passe
j'imagine c'est que vu comment la
question de michael est formulée on va
avoir tendance à d'abord utilisé la
première approche
mais si on ne pense pas immédiatement à
un parent avec deux enfants dont un
garçon
on va passer à la 2e tactique on peut
imaginer qu environ la moitié des sondés
de michael fond cette transition vers la
deuxième tactique auquel cas on prédit
ray quelque chose autour de 42% en
particulier ce qui est intéressant c'est
que la réponse du sondage de michael
révèle en fait davantage de choses sur
la manière dont on réfléchit et donc la
psychologie des sondés de michael que
sur la nature mathématiques des
probabilités
oui car ces probabilités sont
contextuelle en particulier la cognition
humaine est une partie importante du
contexte et qui a conduit au résultat du
sondage
d'ailleurs maintenant qu'on a compris ça
on peut s'aventurer à faire d'autres
prédictions par exemple aussi étrange
que cela puisse paraître il me semble
que l'âge de michael est un facteur
important dans le résultat du sondage
en effet les gens qui ont autour de 30
ans comme michael sont en quelque sorte
entre la partie enfants et la partie par
an puisqu'il ya des parents parmi les
gens de notre âge mais tous ne le sont
pas et du coup on peut imaginer que la
moitié des abonnés de michael où on
pensait davantage aux enfants et l'autre
aux parents mais si michael avait 15 ans
j'imagine que la réponse du sondage
serait davantage proche de 1 2 me et
s'il avait 50 ans elle serait davantage
proche de un tiers
on prend les paris une petite annonce je
serai à l'école polytechnique mercredi
soir à 19h à priori à l'amphi becquerels
pour faire une introduction à
l'altruisme et fication et en
particulier au choix de carrière à fort
impact
donc c'est une présentation à
destination des étudiants de l'école
polytechnique mais bien sûr n'importe
qui est plus que le bienvenu pour avoir
ce genre de réflexion collectif autour
de comment faire un maximum de bien avec
nos propres carrières et le lendemain le
18 avril je serai
à l'événement scianna de l'école télécom
sudparis à evry pour parler
d'intelligence artificielle dernière
fois je vous ai présenté l'énigme des
deux enfants et beaucoup de gens ont
pensé que ma réponse était un poisson
d'avril alors que pas du tout j'étais
très sérieux dans la vidéo quand je
disais que le contexte était absolument
indispensable pour affiner les réponses
à cette question et de façon très
générale dans les problèmes lorsqu'on a
une approche bélizienne et bien toute
information dans un énoncé est
susceptible de modifier nos crédence sur
la rue la bonne réponse à donner et en
particulier si je rajoute ch'ti vivement
que l'un des enfants est un garçon né un
hardi ça change la réponse donc les
informations dans le temps et non c'est
ont un impact vraiment important sur ce
qu'il faut croire projet arbogast fait
toutefois la remarque que la solution by
then que j'ai présentée était une
solution dans laquelle en fait
finalement il n'y a pas que le sachant d
dans la réponse c'est pas vraiment la
priorité de thé sachant d mais ça prouve
a été doté sachant d et d'autres choses
et notamment lorsqu'on applique la
formule de base et qu'on doit faire
c'est ce terme d'expérience de penser il
faut imaginer la probité de voir une
phrase comme l'un d'eux est un garçon on
est obligé d'utiliser des choses qui
sont au-delà de la simple théorie des
données lorsqu'on considère en tout cas
que les théories à considérer son garçon
garçon garde simplifie garçons et
fichiers et cette remarque est tout à
fait valide est en effet en un sens la
probabilité de cette donnée données
étant l'un d'eux est un garçon
la probabilité de cette donnée sachant
garçon garçon par exemple est un terme
mal défini et ça ça revient à dire que
la théorie que l'on a considéré la
théorie garçon garçon n'est pas vraiment
une théorie prédictive
elle ne répond pas aux critères des
théories prédictive comme on en a parlé
dans les pilotes sur la formule du
savoir va se voir l'épisode 3 et ça
c'est un aspect extrêmement important en
fait de la formule de base pour qu'elle
soit appliquée vraiment rigoureusement
il faudrait idéalement uniquement
considéré des théories qui sont vraiment
prédictive
ici on déroule le fil 2 qu'est-ce qu'on
entendra non par une théorie prédictive
je prétends tout cas dans le livre la
forme du savoir et dans des vidéos à
venir que on est obligé d'en revenir à
des fondements très fondamentaux et
notamment
à l'algorithmique pour pouvoir donner un
sens à ce qu'est une théorie prédictive
et on en revient petit à petit au
formalisme de ce bonhomme ne vous
inquiétez pas on y viendra
et je suis tout à fait d'accord avec le
fait de dire que la solution de
l'épisode président n'était pas
entièrement bélizienne mon sens on n'a
pas considéré des théories vraiment
prédictive ou bien sûr idéalement
j'aurais dû vous parler de tout ça mais
on y vient tout doucement et il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire sur danis mme
et donc on y va petit pas est forcément
en chemin je veux pas pouvoir utiliser
les marteaux piqueurs que j'introduirai
dans les épisodes futurs
ceci dit il y aurait encore beaucoup
plus à dire sur cette énigme des deux
enfants ça est une énigme qui est
vraiment fascinante est vraiment trois
vidéos ces trois vidéos que j'en parle
ne suffisent pas à explorer tous les
trucs fabuleux qu'il ya derrière ces
pays et quelque chose me dit qu'on en
parlera longuement dans le prochain
épisode d'action elle espère que j'avais
mais cette vidéo qui clôt un petit peu
cette partie initiale de cette série
soit formé de bèze où on a vraiment
parler de la forme du pays la partir de
la semaine prochaine on parle en un peu
plus de sciences et des fondements des
sciences en particulier ou parlera de ce
qui est socialement comme l'alternative
organismes ont en tout cas qui est
quelque chose de très près dominant au
couple sein de la communauté
scientifique à savoir la notion de frais
kantisme si vous avez aimez cette vidéo
pensez à la ligue et à la commentaires à
partager pensez à vous abonner pour les
futurs épisodes
merci aussi peur pour leurs dons mais
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois
oui devant moi il ya un ensemble de
cartes de divers nombre et je vais vous
demander d'en trouver un qui soit
composé de deux cartes dont au moins une
est noir alors y en a beaucoup en fait
mais considéré juste le premier cas que
vous trouviez qui satisfasse cette
condition de cartes dont au moins une et
noir regardez bien fait pose si
nécessaire et maintenant vous pouvez
répondre dans le petit sondage qui
s'affiche là haut
l'autre carte de ce pack est le premier
paquet que vous ayez trouvé avec deux
cargos au moins une est noire et elle
elle aussi noir ou bien est-elle quelle
est donc la probabilité que ce couple
est alors de filles at elle changé ou
non de nouveau analysons toutes les
possibilités pour chaque enfant il y a
une chance sur deux que trois garçons
une chance sur deux que ce soit une
fille
de plus il ya à priori autant de chance
de naître un lundi à mardi
n'importe quel jour de la semaine soit
une chance sur celle ci nous éliminer
toutes les possibilités
n'ayant pas de filmer un mari il nous en
reste alors 27 dont 13 au port de file
la probabilité d'avoir 26.6 est donc de
13 sur 27 l'information du jour
si anodine en apparence ne semble
finalement pas l'être tant que ça